So now that we have seen two policies
that try to approximate LRU replacement,
let's see if we understood
how NMRU works.
Suppose we have a fully associative
cache with only four lines and
it's choosing NMRU replacement.
Starts out empty,
none of the lines contain any blocks.
And suppose the processor accesses
blocks in the following order.
It accesses something in Block A,
then again something in Block A,
then something in Block B,
then something in Block A,
then something in Block C, then
something in Block A, then something in
Block D, then something in Block A,
then something in Block E.
A, A, A, A, and
finally something in block B.
The question for you.
What's the smallest
number of cache misses
we will have on this sequence
of accesses, and what's
the largest number of cache misses
that we might have on these accesses?